Hello and welcome,
everyone, to the active inference
institute. This is session one of the
course physics as Information Processing
with Chris Fields. First we'll have
Ander Aguirre and Chris Fields.
Introduce themselves. And then we'll
carry on with the first lecture. Here.
Check out the video description for a
link to the course course overview
website where you can ask questions that
will be answered asynchronously register
to participate in the discussions,
which happen about two weeks after each
of the six lecture sessions and just
learn more about this area. So thank you
both so much for joining into this
adventure. We are starting now. And
first, please, Ander Aguirre, introduce
yourself. And then Chris introduction
and lecture. Thank you.
Hello. So I'll be the course assistant.
I'm a postdoc in math, specializing in
improbability, and I have a deep
interest in the physics of information.
And I've been familiar with Chris's
papers for a while. So, yeah, just here
to learn myself.
Thank you, Andrew. And thank you,
Daniel. I'm Chris Fields and
I'll be presenting this course in six
sessions and Aguirre will
be organizing discussion sessions after
each of those. And all of this is
explained on the course website.
So let's start.
This is a course on physics as
information processing, and this first
session will be historical perspective
on the idea that physics is
or is about information processing.
And I'll just start with a few
quotations that span the middle of the
20th century from Wittgenstein in
1920s saying the world is all that is
the case. So defining the world in terms
of facts, not objects.
Landauer in the early 60s proclaiming
that information is physical.
And then John Archibald Wheeler, who in
many ways is the grandfather of this
era, recently stating
it is it from Bit. So things
come from information, I E bitstrings.
And if nothing else, this shows that
formulations of this idea get pithier as
the 20th century rolls on.
But the history goes back
farther clearly than the 20th century.
But I'm only going to really talk about
a piece of it and the
timeline that I'll actually discuss
today. The most relevant history of this
idea goes back to the mid 19th century.
And the first specific thing
I'll talk about is Clausia's definition
of entropy. But with the beginning of
the understanding of thermodynamics and
the role of information in
thermodynamics, you get this very
interesting multidisciplinary
progression of ideas that
incorporates the beginning of quantum
theory.
And the beginning of quantum theory can
kind of be dated to the first Solve
conference in 1928 and the
famous debate between Bohr and Einstein
over whether quantum theory is about
knowledge, information or objects
things. But it incorporates
a lot of work in computer science and
logic and mathematics. So,
interestingly, computer science was Born
effectively in the mid 30s with the work
of Church and Turing, which very rapidly
converged with the work in physics. So
today we'll be talking about both
computer science and physics.
And then in the second half of the 20th
century, this just exploded into a huge
area. And in consequence
of that mid 20th century development,
we're beginning to see a new idea about
physics which is roughly encapsulated in
quantum information theory. And the new
idea is this. It's that what physics is
actually about is information transfer
across boundaries and the
information we can represent. The
information transfer like this. And this
is a convention I'll use. A boundary is
always a blue ellipse. And the
agents that are exchanging information
across this boundary are conventionally
called Alice and Bob, which is just a
more polite way of saying A and B.
And when you think about this picture,
it becomes clear that what physics is
really about is communication. And this
is a wild redescription of
the idea of what physics is compared to
the ideas of Newton or LaPlace
or even the 19th century ideas.
And it's very different from the idea
that's been preserved in 20th
century physics in
the lineage of Einstein and others
who viewed classical physics
as, in a sense,
either as completely fundamental or as a
fundamental adjunct to quantum theory.
So this way of thinking about physics
is a very deeply quantum theoretic way
of thinking about physics. And where
we're going in this course today is
really how did this all happen?
It's the origin story.
And then in the next session, I want to
discuss quantum information theory
explicitly and in particular, how
quantum theory makes this conclusion
that physics is about communication very
simple and obvious, much more obvious
than it is in classical physics where it
takes work to formulate this idea.
Then in the next session, we're going to
talk about semantics and how
observations become meaningful to the
agents who make them and hence how
actions become meaningful to the agents
who make them. Then in August,
we'll talk about communication theory a
little bit more explicitly and talk
about how agents employ multiple
communication channels when they're
communicating. And this
is obvious when you think of people
communicating, they not only talk to
each other, they look at the same
things, they point to things, et cetera.
So this is what I mean by multiple
communication channels. Then in
September, we'll leverage that
discussion to talk about how spacetime
actually emerges from communication.
And this is one of the most important
aspects, I think, of quantum information
theory. It provides us with a way of
viewing spacetime as an emergent
phenomenon, that communication is what
is fundamental in some ontological
sense, and the box in which
it happens, spacetime is not.
So the final session in October will
talk about applications to biology via
the free energy principle and future
directions both in physics and biology
and elsewhere. So it's going to be an
interesting ride. I'm keeping formalism
to a minimum because we're directing
this toward the broad array of people
who are interested in active inference
and who are involved with the Active
Inference Institute. And I would ask you
to hold questions because we have a lot
to get through in an hour for the
interactive discussion and for the
discussion forum.
So I hope I explain things well enough
that all of the concepts will be
understandable. If not,
Wikipedia is actually a wonderful
resource in this area for just
definitions of terms. So if there's
anything that just a term that is a trip
up, try Wikipedia. It's probably a very
good source for what these terms mean.
So let's start our story,
as I said, begins in the 19th century.
And in the mid 19th century,
lots of physicists were devoting their
efforts to figuring out how to make
better steam engines. And one
question that arises when you're trying
to design a steam engine is what happens
physically when you add heat to a
system at constant temperature? So if
you're building a steam engine, you've
got a boiler, because you need to make
steam. And as you turn up the heat to
your boiler, you get more steam,
but the temperature doesn't change. So
this is a mystery. What is the heat
actually adding to the boiler that
is not increasing the temperature?
And Clausius responded to
this question in a way that's sort of
typical for a physicist or a
mathematician. Since he didn't know what
the answer was, he just invented a new
name for whatever it was and gave it a
formal definition. So he called it
entropy, which is a made up word that,
if it was translated from the Greek,
would roughly mean transformation
content in trophy.
And he represented it by a
simple equation that the change in this
new concept entropy, which is always
called S, is just equal to the change
in heat Q at constant temperature t.
So obviously, this equation just
reformulates the question in declarative
form, saying whatever this stuff is,
its changes in this stuff are just
changes in heat at constant temperature.
Well, heat is energy. And this wasn't
completely recognized in the mid 19th
century, but the way you'll see this
equation in a current textbook is DS is
the change in energy at constant
temperature. So even more commonly, you
would see it written as the change in
energy is equal to the temperature times
the change in entropy. It's the most
common sort of textbook way of seeing
this. But the question, of course, is,
what is this quantity? What is this
entropy? What does this concept mean?
And about 15 years after Klausius
proposed it, Boltzman had the key
insight, which is that entropy
is a measurement of our uncertainty
about the state the system is in.
And in particular,
he again, of course, went to formalism
and said, the entropy S is equal to
some constant times
the number of states that the system can
be in that look the same to us.
And since that number of states is
enormous, the way to make that
manageable is to take the log of the
number of states. The natural log is ln.
And this constant k is called
Baltimore's constant.
And Baltimore was able to do this
because he subscribed to a radical,
very unpopular theory that material
things, including gases like air,
were made of atoms and heat
made the atoms move around. And as you
increase the amount of heat, the atoms
can move in many different ways. So the
number of states that they can be in
that look the same to us increases. And
that's what entropy is. It's this
increase in the number of states that
the system can be in that all look
the same to us with the measurements
that we can make. And since they look
the same to us, we're uncertain about
exactly what state they're in.
So entropy is a measure of uncertainty.
This was really the beginning of modern
physics. Because what it says
now is that decreasing uncertainty
requires energy. It links a measurement
of uncertainty to a measurement of
energy. And if you think about the
uncertainty principle in quantum theory,
the core idea of the uncertainty
principle is you can't measure a system
without disturbing it. So to
actually act on a system requires
energy. And that's what you have to do
to get information. So here's Boltzman,
basically, inventing quantum theory.
So we're going to fast forward by
another 15 years, to 1900.
And in 1900, Planck solved this
problem called the black body radiation
problem, which was basically how much
heat does your hot boiler give off into
the air? And all
of the measurements of the heat that hot
boilers gave off to the air ran into
problems in classical physics and caused
contradictions and quantities that
went to infinity. And all of that was
bad. So many people were trying to solve
this problem, and Planck solved it by
making a simple postulate. He said the
energy of the radiation is proportional
to its frequency. So its color in the
case of light. And if you go higher
frequency, you end up in ultraviolet and
X rays and gamma rays. If you go to
lower frequency, you go into microwaves
and radio and all of that. So this is
a nice way of talking about radiation.
And it turned out that this solved the
problem. I mean, just assuming this
simple proportionality relationship
produced spectra for black body
radiation that worked, that matched what
you saw experimentally. Well, this means
something very important. It means
because this number h, the
proportionality constant called plaque's
constant, is a number. It's Finite.
It means that energy comes in discrete
units of H. You can have one H or two H
or 10 million H, but you can't have half
an H of energy.
So it's quantized. And this is widely
recognized as the birth of quantum
theory. But of course, we should have
known this already. If we just thought a
little bit. Right. We Know that changes
of energy are proportional to changes in
entropy by temperature.
And we know that entropy is a measure of
the number of states, and numbers of
states are just numbers. You can have
one state, two states, three states, 10
million states, 100 billion states,
but they're all just a number,
one up. And it's
not infinite. There's not an infinite
number of states unless you have an
infinite amount of energy, which you
don't have. So we knew already
that entropy could only take discrete
values. And since energy and entropy are
basically the same thing, we knew
already that energy could only take
discrete values. So we could have
realized in 1900 that energy is
quantized because the number of states
is quantized. So it
shouldn't have really been a mystery why
energy was quantized, but it was a
mystery, and it stayed a mystery, and it
said, still a mystery. People still
debate the meaning of quantum theory,
but another thing we could have known in
1900 was something very important,
and it's that this quantum of action,
planck's constant, which has units of
action, which is energy times time, is
intimately related to Boltzman's
constant. And Boltzman's
constant has units of energy
over temperature. But this
wasn't actually understood until the
1950s. No one really figured that
this out. There was this relation until
the 1950s. And when it was figured out,
it was figured out by a guy named Jean
Carlo Wick. And he introduced this
notion of the Wick rotation by realizing
that if you have an equation in
classical physics, and in it,
there's the term one over KT. You can
always replace that one over KT with
this other expression. It over h bar. H
bar is just h divided by two pi, and
you'll get an equation that's valid in
quantum theory. And this is typically
described in textbooks as a trick. And
whenever something in physics is
described as a trick, what that really
means is it's something we don't
understand. And lots
of papers have been written about the
meaning of the WIC rotation.
But to start to understand the WIC
rotation, I want to look at this
equation a little bit.
One over KT is one over in energy,
and it over h bar is
one over in energy. Since h bar is units
of energy times time, we have time
in this equation, and then we have this
factor, I, which is typically thought of
as just an imaginary number. So it's the
square root of minus one. And what's
this I doing in this equation? And in
fact, you see factors of it over h bar.
If you're familiar with quantum theory
everywhere in quantum theory.
So what's the meaning of this imaginary
number? And if
you just think of it or of I as
this arbitrary imaginary number that
somehow renders the equation mysterious,
then the whole of quantum theory is
mysterious, but the Wick rotation is
very mysterious. But what I is actually
is an operator. And if you
think of the real numbers as an axis,
which is always drawn horizontally. So
here it is. Here's zero, and the
axis is pointing that way. I'm sorry, I
can't get the camera really far enough
away to see my arm here. So what is I?
I is actually an operator that rotates
the whole real axis by 90 degrees.
So if you see a plot of complex numbers,
then the real numbers go this way, and
the, quote, imaginary numbers go that
way. So what multiplying by I has done
is rotate by 90 degrees. And of course,
if you do I squared, you rotate twice by
90 degrees by arm would do this, but you
end up pointing that way, and those are
the negative numbers. So I is
an operator that rotates something by 90
degrees, and if you rotate four times by
90 degrees, you're back to the identity.
So I to the fourth is one.
So this tells us something very
interesting, which is that what the WIC
rotation is really talking about is a
rotation. It's a geometrical equation.
And in July, we'll come back
to this and really probe what this Wick
rotation means physically.
But as I said, this wasn't understood to
the 1950s, and by the 1950s, a lot had
happened. So quantum theory had been
developed. Bohren Einstein had had their
debate. Particle accelerators had been
built. The atomic bomb had been built.
Nuclear physics was well in its way,
so an enormous amount of practical
physics had been done. Quantum theory
was highly developed. People were
starting to think about quantum field
theory before they made this simple
realization that's formulated in the
Wick rotation. So this is a harboring of
things to come. But before we continue
in physics, we need to backtrack in time
a little bit and look at what the
mathematicians were doing. So across the
hall in the math department, one year
after the Solve conference in 1929,
kurt Godel proved his famous first
incompleteness theorem. And the theorem
states that no formal system that
contains arithmetic can be both
consistent and complete.
And that means that either there are
true statements that aren't provable in
the formal system, or there are false
statements that are provable, or, of
course, both. And Godel's
proof is actually extremely simple.
Almost all of the work in the proof is
setting up all of the notation and
procedures and so forth to formulate
within arithmetic the
sentence, this sentence is not provable.
And once you have that sentence
formulated within arithmetic, then the
conclusion of the proof is obvious. If
you can prove the sentence, this
sentence is not provable, then you've
proved something that's false. And if
you can't prove it, then there are
sentences that you can't prove in
arithmetic. So this was incredibly bad
news for mathematicians who thought that
finite discrete operations, which is
what proofs are and also what
computations are, can exhaustively
enumerate the facts and this was the
assumption behind Wittgenstein's claim
that the world is all that is the case,
the world is a collection of facts. And
optimistically, he thought that first
order logic would allow us to enumerate
all those facts and we'd be done dreams
of a final theory again.
So Godel's Theorem means that no system
with finite capabilities, no system that
can just do finite discrete operations,
can fully describe its environment. It
will always be in an environment where
there are true things that aren't
provable or false things that are
provable. But I think more relative
to a discussion of agents is that it
means that no agent can describe itself.
Any agent's theory of itself will
either contain true statements that it
can't derive or false statements, or it
will either miss true statements that it
can't derive or wind up deriving things
that are false about itself. Of course,
we see this in psychology all the time.
So an immediate consequence of Godel's
Theorem was an intense investigation of
what computation actually is, what it
meant to talk about finite discrete
operations. And two leaders of this
were, of course, Church and Turing. And
here's a picture of a Turing machine,
which is just a little device with a
couple of tapes and a tape reader and a
simple logic unit that either writes a
one or a zero if it sees a one or a
zero. And they defined a computation
as a process that can be implemented in
finite time by such a machine or by
Church's lambda calculus or by any of
the now hundreds of other methods that
are provably equivalent to a Turing
machine. So what does this mean?
It means that computation is a physical
process that can be mechanized and it
turns out, mechanized in any one of a
huge array of ways. It means that many
different implementations of any
computation are possible. So I can do it
on a Turing machine, I can do it on my
laptop, I can do it on my head, et
cetera. The most important things it
means is that there are questions with
no computable answer. This is the
Revenge of Godel's theorem. And two of
the most famous questions of this kind
are given some arbitrary program. Will
it halt? Will it get to an answer in
finite time? And the answer to
that question is this is undecidable.
No procedure can figure this out.
And the other undecidable
question is, given some arbitrary
program, what function does it compute?
And you'd think that would be simple,
that you can read a program and figure
out what function it computes. But it
turns out that is undecidable. That
cannot be done by any finite process.
So this was another
body blow to the goal of understanding
everything with finite discrete
processes. But it also set the stage for
something new. It set the stage for
thinking about an agent who interacts
with a computational process by giving
it an input and then looking at its
output sometime later.
And this, of course, will look familiar
because I've included the blue ellipse,
which is the boundary, which these days
we call a user interface.
And the user interface just allows some
finite action on the system and then the
ability to observe some finite response
by the system. So we can now ask what
can Alice determine by acting in some
finite way and then making some finite
number of observations I. E. Receiving
some finite number of outputs from the
system that she's acting on.
And the first 20 years of this produced
a large number of answers, all of them
negative. So to go back to Turing, he
proved that Alice can't tell what's
implementing the function that she sees
being implemented. She can't tell
whether a given input will lead to an
output. That's the halting problem.
Shannon showed that Alice can't tell
what the inputs mean to the system.
His whole theory of communication is
completely independent of semantics.
And his theory of communication actually
accurately describes what Alice can
observe. Rice is the
one who proved that you can't determine
what program is generating the outputs.
And then Moore proved a very similar
result in a completely different formal
setting of general cybernetics that you
can't tell what process is generating
the outputs by finite observation. But
what Alice can do is build a predictive
model of what generates the output she
sees in response to her inputs and test
it by designing new inputs. And this
is, of course, as Karl Popper told us,
the process that we call science. So
Alice can do science even though she
can't answer any of these fundamental
questions.
Now, this, of course, has a huge
technological consequence since
this theory of computation tells us that
processes are effectively virtual.
We don't know what they are and we can't
determine what they are except in
theory. By making a theory
technologically, it means we're free to
use virtualization everywhere because we
have to deal with it anyway. And this
allows us to build multilevel
architectures. It means that we can
architect computers where no layer of
the computation has any idea what's
going on below or above it and doesn't
need to. And that's what makes practical
programming possible. So from these
no go theorems that tell you what you
can't do, you actually get an enormous
boost into it and
use to probe the world and
develop theories and on and on and on.
So in a sense, Godel birthed not
only computer science, but practical
computing by showing us that
virtualization is just the way the world
works. So now let's go back to physics
where these ideas were replicated,
basically reintroduced, reinvented by
Feynman in developing his path
integral formulation of quantum theory.
And basically what Feyman realized was
that in any physical process,
the observer Alice prepares some
state that she's interested in. She
prepares some input to an experiment.
Then she lets something happen, and then
she sees what the result of the
experiment is. And the canonical
experiment in physics is scattering.
You fire two protons at each other,
and they intersect someplace, and stuff
comes out, and you measure the stuff
that comes out. And what
you can measure is momentum and spin
energy, things like that position.
So these processes
conserve the total values of the things
you can measure. So in particular, they
preserve momentum and angular momentum,
and they preserve other things that
are harder to measure and are only
approximately conserved anyway, like
Lepton number. But Feynman's
contribution to this way of thinking
about experiments was to say, look, if
you want to understand the output, you
have to sum over all of the possible
processes that could have produced the
output from the input, no matter how
improbable they are.
So the famous idea from Feynman
diagrams is if you have an electron
that's scattering off an atom, you
measure the initial state of the
electron that you've generated with an
accelerator or something, and you
measure the final state, which involves
momentum and spin and so forth. And for
all you knew, partway through
the process, the electron disappeared,
and an entire universe appeared and
then annihilated with a copy of an
entire anti universe, and the electron
came back out. And you have to include
processes like that if you really want
to understand and correctly predict the
outcomes of your measurements. And
Murray Gelman lifted
the bumper sticker slogan from Th White
and the once and Future King everything
not explicitly forbidden is mandatory.
That sums up Feynman's idea.
And this is called the totalitarian
principle, since it's what's written in
Th White's book on the kingdom of the
ants, for which everything not
explicitly forbidden is mandatory.
So let's think about a real example
that's a bit actually, it's the same as
scattering. The ultimate scattering
experiment in physics is a black hole.
Stuff goes into the horizon, stars,
whole galaxies, whatever. Something
happens, and stuff comes out. And what
comes out is Hawking radiation,
and information is
conserved if the information in the
Hawking radiation is actually the same
as the information in the stuff that
went in. And conservation
is not qualitative. It's quantitative.
It's only the quantity of information
that's supposed to be preserved. And you
can ask, how much is the information
that's being emitted by a black hole
that's emitting Hawking radiation? And
Beckenstein was the one who figured this
out, using an incredibly simple
argument. But I'll just give the answer
here. The answer is that the total
entropy of the black hole is its area
divided by four,
and the area in this equation has
to be computed in Planck units, which
are units where Planck's constant and
the speed of light and boltzman's
constant and other interesting things
are all set equal to one. So one
Planck area is the Planck length
squared, which turns out to be about ten
to the minus squared. So this
is that black holes are the most
entropic entities we know of.
So a black hole about this big with
a radius of about a meter has an entropy
of about ten to the 70th, which is, of
course, an astonishingly big number,
and a black hole with
the area of the sun. So a moderate sized
cosmological black hole, a real thing
that we can observe with a gravity wave
telescope or something, has an entropy
of about ten to the 79th. And really
big black holes, which are bigger than
the entire solar system, have entropies
into the ten to the
something. So these are enormously
entropic entities.
But Beckenstein didn't just tell us
that. He told us something about the
structure of the interface, the horizon
of a black hole. And this is what he
told us.
You can compute entropy in bits just by
using logs, base two
instead of logs based e, natural logs.
And that's just multiplying the natural
log by about 1.4.
So we can write the entropy of black
hole, of black hole in units of bits,
and it's about a over six. So what does
this mean to say that we can think of
the entropy in terms of bits? What it
says is that we can think of the
interface in terms of a bit array,
and we can think of all of these bits
as encoded on this interface
at a density of one bit every
roughly six
plank lengths squared, six plank areas.
So this is an incredibly dense encoding
in a black hole.
And it's an interesting idea about black
holes. But what gets really interesting
is what happens when you generalize it.
And of course, physicists are prone to
generalization, and that's what happened
next.
Gerard to Hooft, almost immediately
thereafter, on the basis of
Beckenstein's work, formulated the
Holographic principle. And what
the Holographic principle says is we can
think of any system as approximately a
black hole. And the only approximation
is the encoding density. The boundary of
any system encodes the information
that we can get about the system at
some density. And the density is less
than the density for a black hole
because we're not black holes. And this
rules out a lot by limiting the amount
of information that you can extract from
a system to the amount of information
that you can actually write on its
boundary. And one of the things that it
rules out is knowing the geometry on the
inside of the system. And to Hoof put it
this way, which I think is a brilliant
thought experiment, he says, look, the
metric inside this system can be so
curved, effectively the space time
inside the system can be so curved that
you could stick an entire universe
inside. And we never know because it
wouldn't change the amount of entropy
number of bits that are encoded on the
boundary. So the inside geometry can be
anything. And you can't find out by.
Looking at the outside of the system.
Now, the Holographic principle almost
follows from classical physics.
There's Euler's theorem,
which tells you about one over R squared
forces, and you can think of the
force as penetrating the boundary at
some density. And the
difference between Euler's theorem and
the Holographic principle is just that
the density in classical physics can go
to infinity. And in the Holographic
principle, it can only go to this
maximal density that's achieved by a
black hole. Why? Because if you try to
get any higher, more information, the
information gets sucked into the black
hole, and you can't get it out.
So the Holographic principle becomes
a guiding principle for thinking about
any physical system and what it means to
extract information from a physical
system. And in fact, we'll talk about
this next time. You can say exactly what
the information encoded on the boundary
of any system is.
And what I'll go through next time is
seeing that the information that's
encoded on the boundary is a
specification of the energy that's being
exchanged by the interaction, which, of
course, is linear in the number of bits.
It's just counting the number of bits.
Okay? So with the Holographic
principle, we now have a complete new
science about systems that are
exchanging finite discrete information
across a boundary by encoding that
information on the boundary and then
reading the information off the
boundary. So here's a
new way of thinking about physical
interaction. Alice writes a message on
her boundary with Bob, and Bob reads
the message off the boundary and
then writes his own new message, which
Alice then reads. And of course, that's
what's happening right now.
I'm writing information by speaking on
an interface, which is effectively the
Internet. And you're reading that
information off the Internet by
listening to it. And when we get time
for questions, you'll be writing
information on the Internet, which I'll
be reading. Now, the key thing about
this new science is that it's
topological. It's about connectivity
across some communication channel,
which we represent as a boundary. It's
not geometric, so it doesn't assume
anything about spacetime. So it
allows us to build a model of
space in particular as an emergent
phenomenon. And it allows us to see
time as not some absolute
external abstraction, but something
that the communicating agents measure
for themselves. And so they each
act in their own time. And we
get a very natural measure of time in
terms of how many bits I see coming
across my boundary. And again, we'll
talk about that in the next couple of
sessions and then talk
about it more thoroughly in September
when we talk about emergent spacetime.
So quantum information theory looks very
different from the physics that came
before, not because it's adopted
a new formalism, the tools of quantum
theory. It's because it's entirely
changed the thinking about what physics
is and what it's about and replace
this idea of forces and balls banging
into each other and all of that with the
idea of communication between agents.
And of course that's familiar from an
active inference perspective. So we can
now back up a little bit to see what
they were doing in classical physics
during this period. Well, let me go on a
little bit. Sorry.
This is just a slide quoting Wheeler,
who of course is the most radical in
terms of impitheist, in terms of
formulating these ideas. But here's his
characterization of this new physics.
It's not reductive. All of
the reasoning is circular. You don't
have smaller things and then yet smaller
things, and then yet smaller things
forever. There are no laws.
So what you see on the interface is
a message. It's not something that's
governed by laws since the beginning of
the universe. There's no continuum.
So there's nothing described by real
numbers. It's all described by integers.
Everything's done in finite dimensional
spaces. And finally, and most
importantly, there's no spacetime box in
which things happen. So think of how
radical this is means. There's no big
bang, there's no big rip,
there's no bouncing universe. All of
those ideas are out the window because
they're classical and they're about
spacetime. And what the new physics
wants to do is derive spacetime out of
basically users experiences.
So the agents here are all observer
participants in Wheeler's language.
But what that just means is agents that
want to communicate and it's their
communication that gives rise to
physics. So now we'll go back to
classical physics and what was
happening, or one thing that was
happening in classical physics at that
time was a lot of thinking about
stochastic causal networks.
And Pearl realized
that if you have any stochastic causal
network that's unidirectional, then
around any node, you can draw what he
called a Markov blanket. And a Markov
blanket is just the set of nodes in the
network that absorb
all outside causation and then transmit
that causation into whatever node you're
interested in and then absorb all
causation coming from the node you're
interested in and transmit it to the
rest of the world. And so we
can redraw that in Part B here,
and it should look very familiar. A
Markov blanket is just a classical
physics way of talking about a
Holographic screen. And the number
of nodes in the Markov blanket,
or in particular the number of degrees
of freedom times the number of nodes,
is just the number of bits that flow
across that Markov blanket. So it's the
entropy of the effective Holographic
screen.
All these ideas were reinvented more or
less independently within classical
physics. And it was from this classical
physics background that Karl
Freston came up with the idea that a
Markov blanket defines a persistence,
at least from an active inference
institute point of view everyone is
familiar with, because it's the
foundation of the idea of active
inference.
Any system that persists
through time does so by making
sure that it doesn't dissolve into its
environment. Well, what does that mean?
It means it persists through time by
maintaining the integrity of its Markov
blanket or the integrity of its
boundary. So this of course is just a
tautology, but it's
a very interesting and very productive
tautology because it says that any
system is using the information it gets
on its boundary from its environment to
build a model of how its environment
behaves. And then it
uses that model to act back on its
environment to test and refine its
model. And again, as Popper told us,
this is just what science is. So what
the free energy principle really tells
us is that all systems are agents that
are doing science all the time.
So physics is effectively not
just the study of communication, but
it's the study of agents doing science
with each other, pairs of agents who are
trying to figure each other out by their
communicative exchanges.
So that's the history of how
we got from 1930s sorry,
1850s thermodynamics to the
free energy principle and
how the free energy principle connects
to these very deep and extremely
radical, especially within context ideas
in quantum theory and quantum cosmology
and computer science. All of which tell
us that the world
we see is a
projection that's being written on our
boundaries by a process that we
have no access to except the
procedure of active inference or the
procedure of science, which is to
formulate predictive models and test
them by doing things in the world and
seeing how the world responds.
So that's it for this session.
The first discussion session which
Andrew is going to lead will be the 3
June at this same time, I E
05:00 European time. And then
my session number two will be in mid
June. And if you look at the course
website, there's this subsidiary
website for interactive Q and A.
And I invite everyone to post questions
and discuss them and hope that
we'll have an interesting exchange and
that everyone
will come to sort of an understanding of
what was talked about today through
discussion. And we'll be interested
in being back in June to see how to
formulate this in quantum theory. So
thank you very much and thank you again,
Daniel, for organizing this and hosting
it and putting together all the
technical things necessary to pull this
off. I could never do that on my own.
Thank you. We're really excited here.
Any closing thoughts? Or andrew, I'd
love to hear your reflection just
briefly. How would you have told that
history or how does that history reflect
on the areas that you're familiar with?
Well, I don't think I have much to add.
I've been mainly interested in the weak
rotation part. I'm excited to hear more
about that, Chris. But no,
I found this to be a very nice summary.
I'm less familiar with the staff on
computation, formal computation,
despite being a mathematician by
training, it was a
little more familiar with all the
physics stuff, but yeah, I thought it
was great. Thank you. All right.
Thank you. I will close it. So in about
two weeks, we'll have the first
discussion. Everyone's welcome to join.
I will share with Honor and Chris the
questions, and we can develop that. And
we'll have that on the course, front end
before the coming discussion. So thanks
again, fellows. See you next time.